[موسيقى]
يعتبر الكثير
من الناس أن عظماء جيبسن هو أفظع أنواع الخمور
التي مروا بها على الإطلاق بأذواق جيمي ميلر
مثل الجوارب المتعرقة وإبر الصنوبر المعدني
والشمام بالإضافة إلى الإطارات مثل المطاط من
الناحية الفنية ، فهي تشبه صفير منسق الأغاني في
الواقع حامضًا ويأسف على أنها
قاسية جدًا  إنه أمر مروع ، ولكن بعد ذلك أصبح
طعمًا مكتسبًا ، حيث أنني الآن لا أستطيع
الحصول على ما يكفي ،
اسمي تريمين أتكينسون ، أنا الرئيس التنفيذي
ورئيس تقطير التقطير المبرد ،
أفضل وصف لي لمذاق معلم
جيبسن هو غاز الحمار وإطلاق النار
في جميع  في نفس الوقت الذي أحبه فيه شخصيًا ،
أعتقد أنه مذاق رائع ، لكن ربما أكون
غريبًا بعض الشيء عندما يصف الرئيس التنفيذي أن
منتجه شيء طعمه مثل
غاز الحمار والنار ، من الآمن افتراض
أن هناك قصة يجب
إخبارها وتلك القصة  كما اتضح أنه
أحد الأساطير الفنية التي
اخترعها كارل جيفرسون في ثلاثينيات القرن الماضي ، وهو
مهاجر سويدي دخن الكثير من السيجار لدرجة
أنه قتل براعم التذوق لديه ، لذلك كان عليه أن
يأتي بشيء مع سو
نكهة قوية يمكن أن تقطعها
وتعطيه تجربة حقيقية ، لذا
أخبر من أين أتى يمكننا أن
نقول إنه يحتوي على الشيح ،
وهذا هو نكهته الأساسية
وكل شيء آخر بعد ذلك سري للغاية
ولكن من فضلك  المزيد عن الشيح
هو نبات ، إنه حقًا عشب يبدو
قليلاً تمامًا مثل غصين به بعض
الأوراق الصغيرة ، ينمو في
كل مكان تقريبًا عندما تأخذ قضمة منه ،
إنه أكثر المواد مرارة
التي يمكن أن تستطيع حقًا  اشترِ 10 - يرجى
المعذرة عن سذاجتي ، ولكن هل يمكن لشخص ما أن
يشرح لماذا يشرب أي شخص هذه
الأشياء ، إن معلم Jepsen هو أحد
تقاليد شيكاغو القديمة في شيكاغو لديه بعض
الأشياء المميزة حقًا مثل
البيتزا ذات الطبق العميق والفاصوليا وبحيرة
ميشيغان أعتقد لماذا  يتم احتضان سوء السلوك
لأن هذه الأشياء
الأخرى لطيفة ولكن السيد هو نوع من
رمز بدس في شيكاغو ، فهو يتيح لنا
أن نكون أنفسنا وأردت الانخراط
مع ميلورد منذ أن بدأت في صنع
الخمر  هنا في شيكاغو لأنها
عنصر أساسي في مشهد الشرب في شيكاغو ،
يشبه الناس إلى حد كبير المواد المضادة الأساسية ، فكم عدد
الطلقات التي يمكن أن تبيعها في
المتوسط 365 يومًا في السنة يأ
ذ الناس 10000 لقطة من مايار لذا فكر في ذل
كل ليلة 10000 لقطة  من
مايلارد تختفي في
أجساد الناس كانت طريقة غريبة حقًا
لقول ذلك